more than 100,000 people live in the
region around the bin le wooden
reservoir lake in the Atlas Mountains
life is hard here many would like to
move away if they could
people like this farmer his fields
overlook the reservoir some 1000 metres
above sea level
egress Bacoor could no longer make a
living farming so he decided to become a
fisherman like his father before him I
wouldn't want my son to become a farmer
like I did it was too hard at least
fishing provides us with more of an
income than we used to have buck or is
the spokesman for a local fishing
cooperative its joined forces with the
Moroccan forestry authority to launch a
campaign against people moving away the
initiative is supported by the German
aid agency GI Z members meet regularly
to discuss issues such as fish stocks
and quotas have a confide affair we
started out by completely reorganizing
the fishing industry because it wasn't
regulated at all people would just go
out on their fishing boats but now they
founded a collective the organization
has a hand in combating poaching it sets
out rules for when people can go fishing
taking spawning season into account when
it's spawning season for the black bass
for example fishermen aren't allowed to
catch the Elephant Man the reservoir was
built in the mid 1950s it used to be a
small mountain lake with two inflows the
plateau used to be home to a range of
far greater biodiversity
over the years heavy rainfall and
flooding uprooted the area's vegetation
the rivers narrowed and in time fish
stocks dropped dramatically the nearby
fishery went to wrack and ruin
in [ __ ] crowd functions as a
biological indicator of the health of
its environment once climate change set
in drought started to disappear from the
region
the fishing collectives project includes
a fish breeding station down in the
valley trout and carp are bred here on
the edge of town once there are a few
weeks old they're released into the
reservoir
that's what address buffer is doing
today he'll be releasing about 100 fish
into the lake the point is to boost the
diversity of fish in its waters I'm so
glad that we have a fish breeding
station here it's a great help because
fish stocks and the reservoir are on the
decline the closer one gets to Rabat
Morocco is capital the more modern
everything looks nearly half the
population still lives from agriculture
staff at the Environment Ministry in
Rabat are learning how to go about
raising money for environmental
protection initiatives Morocco
desperately needs funds for
environmental conservation efforts in
the Atlas Mountains even the minister
herself takes part Morocco is very
vulnerable to climate change we have
seen temperatures climb so we're
fighting drought in many parts of the
country further problems include
desertification erosion and natural
disasters
the harvests in the valleys of the Atlas
Mountains are increasingly scant there
are a few young people left in the
region most of them head to the cities
as soon as they can
the fishing project based at the
reservoir is also looking to boost
tourism for now only about 100 visitors
make it to the remote mountainous region
per year fishing tourism is hardly
lucrative not least because there's no
infrastructure to support it
gregory sena khat is an intrepid tourist
from france he's a huge fishing
enthusiast and comes here regularly
he loves the beauty and tranquility this
carp weighs about 5 kilos and would have
been swimming at a depth of about 7
meters I used corn as a bait I love it
here it's very relaxing the Sun is great
it's lovely here he also appreciates the
traditional Moroccan hospitality locals
even help him pitch his tent but for the
time being at least there isn't enough
tourism to improve the local standard of
living the situation might improve once
fish stocks have been replenished and
can provide locals with the livelihood
then they'll be less likely to move away
and then hopefully more visitors will
come to explore this beautiful but
troubled corner of Morocco